aria-live allows developers to
mock a part of the page as live,
in the sense that updates should be
communicated to users in a timely manner
rather than if and when they happen
to explore that part of the page.
One example might be a status
message which appears as a result
of either a user action or
an external event.
If this message is important enough
to grab aside a user's attention,
we can direct and assist
a technology user's attention to it
by setting an aria-live attribute on it.
When an element has
an aria-live attribute we refer
to the part of the page containing it
and its descendants, as a live region.
aria-alive has three allowable values,
off, polite, and assertive.
Off is the default value.
It can be specified
explicitly if need be, but
not setting it aria-live attribute
at all will have the same effect.
aria-live = "polite" tells
us assistive technology,
alert the user to this change when
you finished whatever you were doing.
It's great to use if something
is important but not urgent and
accounts for
the majority of aria-live use.
In this example we have a chat
widget which uses aria-live
to reflect the most
recent chat activity.
When a new check message appears it'll
be announced to a screen reader user
once any in progress
utterance has finished.
aria-live = "assertive" tells
assistive technology to interrupt what
ever it's doing and alert the use
to this change immediately.
This is only for important and
urgent updates, such as a status message
like, there has been a server error and
your changes are not being saved,
please refresh the page.
Or update to an input field as
a direct result of a user action,
such as buttons on a step or widget.
In this case, once this alert bar has
some content, it'll interrupt whatever
the user was doing with
an announcement of its content.
To demonstrate this in practice,
here's a demo of aria-live use
in the custom number input.
You can see the dom for
the custom number input on the right.
We have a container element
with a roll of spin button.
Then a span containing the numerical
value and an Add and Subtract button.
The span within the numeric value has
an aria-live value of assertive, meaning
whenever it changes, whatever speech
is in progress should be interrupted.
One of the thing to notice is
I've used aria described by,
to associate the element with
this bit of help text underneath.
So I'll probably hear that once
I set focus on the element.
I'm going to turn on Chromebooks light,
tap to the element, and
then I should hear the label and it's
going to start reading the description.
Then I'm going to use the up
arrow to add ten to the value.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[SOUND]
>> Number input demo.
Current value.
Spin button.
Use add and subtract buttons or
up and down arrows.
10.
>> Great.
So it immediately told me the new value,
and interrupted what it was saying.
I can do that again.
>> 20.
>> Or use the mouse.
>> [SOUND] 30.
[SOUND] 20.
>> Or use the screen reader.
>> Add button.
[SOUND] 30.
>> And the same thing happens.
So those are the basics of aria-live.
We have just a couple of tips for
working with aria-live
regions in practice.
Firstly, your aria-live region should
probably be in the initial page load.
This is not a hard and fast rule,
but if you're having difficulty with
an aria-live region,
this could be one of the issues.
Secondly, different screen readers and
assistive technologies react differently
to different types of changes.
For example, it's possible to trigger an
alert on some screen readers by toggling
a descendant element's hidden
style from true to false.
But this technique does
not work on others.
So if you're having issues with
getting an aria-live region to speak,
experiment with some different
types of content changes
to see what works on
the platforms you're targeting.